[Music]
[Music]
raising finance I in my first four years
of being in property so from the ages of
some starting at 17 so from the ages of
17 up until 21 I borrowed from family
and friends not banks not mortgages but
borrowed actual hard cash took in my
bank from friends and family a hundred
and twenty five thousand pounds and I
asked for money
not once zero so I'm going to just give
you a little example and a little
template that are used to have people
giving you money and I'll tell you the
structure of how I use that and how I
paid that without asking for money and
how you can do that too if you want to
know all right so let me just say this
firstly the first thing you want to do
before you start asking not asking
before you start seeking to get money
off people you see a good plan so you
need to be able to say if I was to get
50 grand what would I do with it if you
know you can invest it really well if
you had 50 grand do real damage with it
but you haven't got 50 grams then you
need to be able to do this if you add
like 50 grand but you don't know what
you don't even have a clear part of what
you do with it and just get trained
first people are you borrowing money off
people you need to down what make sure
that you you invest it well agreed so if
you want to borrow from a person like
your grandma or something like that the
reason you don't ask is because there's
nothing more unattractive than a
desperate person and if you're desperate
you're like really and you ask oh you
know desperate written all over your
forehead and they're gonna be so turned
off you ain't gonna get payment so
instead the way to do this is what you
need to do is okay
give you the steps step one is to ask
them about their business or their work
or what it is that they're doing and
what's going on ask them tell me what's
going on with your work what's going on
with your business
you know you might know little about it
ask them about it why do you do that yes
good job because your last them then
you'll listen and then what they will
always do is then they will ask you the
same question
if you want someone to ask you a
specific question just ask them first
not asking you back it's crazy
people stupid how are you I'm fine
thanks and how are you want to currency
notes I just have to do that and now you
asked me yet because it always how it
goes what do you do for a living I'm a
plumber what about you true or true so
ask them about their business and their
work what are you doing what's going on
half business a life they'll tell you oh
yeah good I'm doing this do that and
presumably yeah you want to be talking
to someone that's got some money so they
might be risk-averse they've got money
in the bank whatever yeah retired now
yeah bit bored oh yeah well how about
you what's going on with you what you
doing these days me so glad you asked
well I am a property investor and then
leave it there to show the property
mister don't go give them a storage
style property investor what you'll find
is now they're asking you questions do
not try and sound to them get them or
anything like that just tell them about
property if you haven't got a property
business yet just tell them oh all I'm
doing is and then tell them so I learned
on the crash course so are you a
property investor so what kind of
investments do you do oh well I'm I'm
part of it I'm part of a family network
are we family here
yeah part of the family Network what we
do is we buy properties and we split
them up a bit than that room by room
it's really cool oh that's interesting
there so what property investing I mean
how long you been doing that well
actually and what I always do I always
tell the bank story because not only are
you telling them how good property is
now kind of successful you're going to
be but you're also you also create a bit
of pain for them so it's just to advance
them okay all right great I know I'm
going quite quick so all I say as I say
I actually even sketch it out sometimes
you can't miss when you're playing golf
or whatever but but I I'm just like yeah
oh so important to mr. HMOs
yeah one of the things I realized that
was crazy is that if I was to put like
50 grand in the bank and save it and
wait 10 years you know it'd only be then
worth thirty six and now go what you get
money depreciates doesn't mean when he
shrinks over time and they'll be
thinking yeah they've got money in the
bank they'll be it that'll be a bit of
pain hey so what I'll do is put my money
into property and you put 50 grand into
a bank and you wait ten years you know
how much it's worth and they'll be like
wow I don't know fifty five six day no
four hundred and they'll say what you
having a laugh tell them explain it you
know it sounds them you just tell them
in a conversational fun way right and
and what they're fine there's nothing
this person is interested
this person's done a bit of economic
study and it's just nice conversation
but for a purpose so you tell them that
and they say yeah so that's why I love
property you know bricks and mortar goes
up over time but think about properties
you get paid twice once he caps
appreciation also in rents so that's
what I do in fact the thing I'm didn't
even call her and then this is the bit
now it's the bit so the step to ask them
about their business to tell them you're
a property investor three answer their
questions deliberately I steer the
conversation then once you've done that
you say I tell you what's even caller:i
I'm getting all their capital
appreciation
without even putting down my own
deposits because what I'm doing now is
I'm working with investors where they
put in the money and I invest it for
them and give them a guaranteed fixed
return on their money so that's really
cool hey no I see you later all right
leave it little tip always leave the
conversation when it's at its highest so
when you get in on the best and you're
like yeah walk away because what
happened is double up oh yeah and now
and they'll want to find you again it
leaves it leaves on a high and then what
will happen is next time you see them
they'll probably just bring it up again
or they might bring it up there and then
but always leave when the conversation
is high but what will happen is at some
point when they know you do that they'll
say to you oh you know um you know we've
got some money tied up in the bank or so
perhaps you know we won't be yeah we
could be offensive our chat about do
similar that's what they'll say and when
they say that you're gonna go boom
you're gonna strip one time you're gonna
sign the suit which is yes no you're
gonna go I'll give you a call I'm gonna
exaggerate it but you're not going to be
excited you're not gonna blow oh you're
just gonna say like oh yeah okay cool
so what kind of returning looking again
10% oh yeah we can easily listen I tell
you what next time I get a deal
perhaps I'll give you a call then when
it passed you how's that sound and
they'll be like yeah yeah cool hey Dan
wait a couple weeks well have you asked
for money at this point not what you've
just told them what you do in fact you
don't even told them they've asked you
and you've been answered but you did it
that way so then when they bring them in
couple weeks and just saying hey yeah
it's pretty it's pretty good looking at
buying it I was about to call one of my
other investors however I thought I'd
call you first because we were just
happen to be talking a couple weeks ago
is that true it's true
so so so yeah so I just wondered if you
wanted to know about that oh yeah cool
yeah yeah what's what bang send them a
heads of terms contract this is how much
I'm looking for this is the return your
get guaranteed if you know this happens
if I die this happens yin-er yin-er boom
and then that's that and then the next
thing you know you'll have money wired
over to you bank you're about to invest
it and you won't even be against your
credit or anything because it's money
that you know the credit score people
Dave another
[Music]